hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
hanging with no clips so here is Karin
Jean-Pierre cringe Jean-Pierre
undoubtedly lying the border is secure
as the Administration has said then why
would we need to send 1500 active duty
U.S troops down there because we need
more work we need more work needs to be
done Peter we put forth a a
comprehensive immigration
legislation and Congress of republicans
in Congress refuse to act and so the
president has used the tools that he has
in front of him uh to uh to prepare
ahead of title 42 lifting as you know
that is happening uh in the next couple
of days and so we are putting DHS
Department of State as putting forth
processes processes to deal to deal with
the changes that are going to be ahead
of us and so that is what's important
here and that's what you've been seeing
for the past several months you've heard
from DHS you've heard from the state
department on what we're putting in
place uh to deal with to to deal with
the Border once title 42 lives you said
yesterday that when it comes to Illegal
migration you've seen it come down by
more than 90 percent where did that
number come from it was I was speaking
this number is I hear you I'm about to
answer them
for a year so if you if The Dramatics
could come down just a little bit The
Dramatics would come down a little bit
dramatic about asking a question about
okay I'm gonna answer so I was speaking
to the parolee program as you know the
president put in place a parolee program
to deal with to deal with certain
countries uh on on ways that we can
limit illegal migration and we have seen
the data has shown us that it has gone
down by more than 90 percent that was
what I was speaking no I'm we're gonna
go we're gonna move
thank you